they need to explain how America with
all its wealth and know how has the
world's highest covert 19 death toll and
today Donald Trump's health secretary
former pharmaceutical lobbyists Alex
Azza told the world health organization
it was partly to blame we must be frank
about one of the primary reasons this
outbreak spun out of control there was a
failure by this organization to obtain
the information that the world needed
and that failure cost many lives then
though he didn't name China it was clear
who he was talking about in an apparent
attempt to conceal this outbreak at
least one member state made a mockery of
their transparency obligations with
tremendous cost for the entire world
Shana stands accused of covering up the
outbreak at first and lying about its
severity but it was able to launch an
unprecedented lockdown which others have
been able to follow the Chinese
President Xi Jingping seemed eager to
try and seize the moral high ground as
he too addressed the whu-oh meeting by
teleconference in order to boost
international cooperation against covert
19 I would like to buy 2 billion u.s.
dollars over two years me to help with
the curve in 19 response and with social
and economic development in affected
countries especially developing
countries Donald Trump says he's not
speaking to Xi Jinping currently even
more so now probably while he's cut
hundreds of millions of dollars of
funding to the World Health Organization
China's just massively increased its
contribution to fighting the pandemic
East America's supports and funding in
the past the World Health Organization
was today having to defend itself from
the unprecedented the u.s. attack the
world doesn't need another plan another
system another mechanism another
committee or another organization it
needs to strengthen implement and
finance the systems and organizations it
has including WTO America was one of the
World Health Organization's biggest
champions and funders under this
president it's abdicated that role and
China is eager to fill the vacuum
ironically the country where coronavirus
originated could find its global
standing and influence is boosted in the
aftermath of this pandemic Dominik
Waghorn Sky News